[музика]
Привіт Україно Привіт українці де б не
були вітаємо друзі Ми раді привітати
всіх вас незалежно де ви зараз
знаходитеся в Україні або поза межами
нашої Батьківщини із днем знань із новим
навчальним роком Ну і незважаючи на
війну прийшов час повертатись до
навчання це дуже важливо адже саме Від
вас залежить майбутнє нашої країни А для
цього треба вчитись
погодьтеся сучасне навчання нині є
різним є очним Коли ви приходите
безпосередньо в класі школи є
дистанційним коли ви навчаєтесь онлайн є
сімейним Ну і навіть міжнародним для тих
хто наразі тимчасово перебуває за
кордоном але ви також маєте змогу
продовжувати навчатись за українською
програмою
в новому навчальному році для вас
підготовлено багато цікавих та корисних
новинок про які ви дізнаєтесь сьогодні
під час першого уроку який Так і
називається повертаюся до навчання його
для вас організували Міністерство освіти
і науки України інститут модернізації
змісту освіти і асоціація
інноваційної та цифрової освіти і ми
вдячні за підтримку ґотеінституту
Федеративної Республіки Німеччини Отже
ми починаємо ми просто зараз привітальне
слово для вас від першої леді України
Олени Зеленського
дорогі діти Вітаю всіх з початком нового
навчального року такого 1 вересня Ані У
вас Ані в нас дорослих без прибільшення
ще ніколи не було ми ще ніколи не
розпочинали новий навчальний рік Під
звуки повітряної тривоги
однак У кожного з нас зараз своя місія
наші військові роблять все щоб здобути
перемогу а ваша місія зараз продовжувати
навчання зараз вся країна б'ється сам за
це щоб у вас було нормально життя зі
школою знаннями а отже перспективами
ви діти вільної країни і саме вам
будувати її майбутнє
і в той же час прошу не забувайте що ви
діти бешкетуйте товаришуйте дивуйтеся
захоплюйтеся не відпускайте дитинство
Дорогі вчителі ви справжні герої Дякую
за вашу працю і знає яке ви зараз
величезне навантаження та
відповідальність але саме тому ви
особливо потрібні вашим учням від вашої
впевненості вашого стану залежить їхній
готовність продовжувати навчання дорогі
батьки
коли трапився перший локдаун нам з вами
здавалося що це
несерйозніший виклик для наших дітей для
нас
виявилося що виклики бувають і ще
серйознішими Але саме карантинний досвід
зараз дуже допомагає організувати
навчання у будь-яких умовах знає що ви
докладаєте величезних зусиль щоб ваші
діти могли отримувати освіту будь ласка
Продовжуйте підтримайте їх та
допомагайте коли діти вчаться країна
перемагає вона сильніша саме знаннями Та
мріями тож дорогі діти вчиться і мріти і
все обов'язково буде і святкові перші
вересня і випускні бали і посмішки
вчителів та батьків
успішного навчального року попри все
повертайтесь до навчання
[музика]
Дякую Пані Олено А тепер до вашої уваги
міністра освіти і науки України Сергій
шкарлет
Вітаю вас друзі з початком нового
навчального року Так цей навчальний рік
є першим з часів завершення Другої
світової війни який ми на жаль
розпочинаємо в умовах воєнного стану
саме тому основне завдання на якому
сконцентрувало свої зусилля Міністерства
освіти і науки України це зробити для
вас всіх освітній процес доступним
безперервним та максимально безпечним ми
розуміємо як ви всі скучили за своїми
друзями
однокласниками вчителями і хочете
повернутися до своїх класів для цього ми
в тих регіонах де це можливо і дозволяє
безпекова ситуація рекомендуємо очне
навчання
забезпечивши школи бомбосховищами
але остаточний вибір формату навчання чи
очного чи дистанційного буде за вами
вашими батьками а також місцевою владою
для тих хто сьогодні знаходиться за
межами країни Ми також надаємо
можливість навчатися за українською
програмою для цього розгортається мережа
українських освітніх хабах в рамках
міжнародної української школи а також
працюють в Польщі Німеччині
Великобританії і Ми продовжуємо
відкривати такі хаби в інших країнах
світу де наразі перебувають українські
учні
незважаючи на те Який формат навчання ви
оберете ми докладаємо всіх зусиль щоб
зробити цей навчальний рік не тільки
цікавим а й корисним для вас всі
п'ятикласники в цьому році вперше
розпочнуть навчання за новою програмою в
рамках реформи нової української школи
також на вас чекають багато приємних
нових можливостей
це і вивчення іноземних мов за
інноваційними методиками і уроків
фізкультури по-новому і нових харчування
і можливість свідомого вибору майбутньої
професії та багато чого іншого над чим
Ми продовжуємо працювати навіть під час
жорсткої війни Російської Федерації
проти нашої держави під час цього уроку
ви дізнаєтесь про ці новинки більш
детально
хочу подякувати нашим учням які складали
в цьому році національний
мультиппредметний тест майже 10 тисяч
учасників тестування отримали найвищі
200 балів хоча б з одного з предметів а
майже 3000 отримали по 200 балів з
кожного з трьох предметів цими
результатами ви не лише розвіяли сумніви
експертів
а й переконливо продемонстрували що всі
Громадяни України мають володіти
українською мовою та знати історію
України
незважаючи на те до якого тестування
готувалися пишаємось з вами Ви як і ми
дорослі Незламні ви гідні майбутнє нашої
держави
І сьогодні я звертаюсь до кожного з вас
повертайтесь до навчання адже саме вам
відбудовувати та розвивати наша
Прекрасну незалежну країну
Вірте в себе ставте перед собою
максимально амбітні цілі і ви
обов'язково їх досягнете усім освітянам
щиро дякую за відданість професії За
мужність і стійкість ви герої освітнього
фронту саме ви формуєте сьогодні еліту
нашої процвітаючої держави бажаю вам
міцного здоров'я миру злагоди і
невичерпано натхнення розвиватися та
змінювати Україну на краще зі святом вас
тримаємось ми сильні ми Україна З
повагою до вас Разом до перемоги
так заінтригував наш пан міністр щодо
новинок які вже чекають наших учнів у
цьому навчальному році цікаво а як буде
виглядати та смакувати новий формат
харчування у школах та взагалі Чи
важливо правильно харчуватися ну
найкраще на ці запитання
відповість відомо що кухар який увійшов
у топ-50 найкращих кухарів світу - Це
Євген Клопотенко нещодавно До речі як ви
знаєте Євген розробив шкільне меню і От
тепер приєднується до нашого з вами
уроку
Ого ти з нами привіт
Всіх вітаю
Я дуже радий всіх бачити Дуже радий
Приймати участь в цьому році тому що я
вважаю що навчання це мабуть
найголовніша річ яка Ну одна головніших
речей яка існує Я особисто навчаюся
безперервно постійно зараз сиджу і
навчаюся
[музика]
насправді буде лише покращуватися будемо
те що ми зробили те що розпочали ось цю
величезну реформу вона вже мав надію
працює і маю надію їжа буде в школах
набагато краще і кожен кожен хто прийде
в їдальню буде насолоджуватися цим але
ще дуже багато роботи треба робити Я
знаю що в деяких інколи їжа буває не
ідеальною інколи страви бувають можливо
не такі як би хотілося не такі як ви
бачите в інтернеті але для цього треба
просто навчити кухарів і зараз півроку
ми будемо їздити
по всій якщо в куха
рів краще краще краще краще щоб їжа
ставали смачнішою і головне щоб вона
приносила задоволення бо якщо ми поїли
Якщо у нас ми не голодні У нас є бажання
навчатися а
якщо ми то Яке там навчання про що ми
можемо лише говорити тому я хочу всіх
поздоровити зразу з тим що ми розпочали
навчальний рік я хочу поздоровитись тих
всім що м-м ми будемо їсти гарно їжа ми
не будемо ми не будемо е-е ми не будемо
їсти шкідливо їжу що це це дуже погано
Нам не треба вона зараз абсолютно І саме
головне хочу всіх е-е закликати щоб ми
всі поверталися до навчання бо це є
гіпер важливо для нас і для України
тобі Дякуємо твої кулінарні заповіді
почули занотували взяли до і в роботу
зараз продовжимо тому що наразі взагалі
дуже важливо кожному українцю в тому
числі і вам друзі демонструвати нашу цей
справжній козацький дух від якого в
захваті весь світ а як же це зробити
запитаєте ви для цього ваші вчителі
просто зараз проходять спеціальне
навчання і будуть навчати вас незважаючи
ні на що мати впевненість у своїх силах
тримати себе в руках і підтримувати
своїх друзів у будь-якій ситуації
вчителів завжди готові прийти вам на
допомогу якщо ви цього потребуватимете
до нас зараз долучається радник
директора інституту модернізації змісту
освіти і Станіслав Куценко
Слава Доброго ранку
вітаю друзі дійсно сьогодні вчителі
проходять курс першої психологічної
допомоги що мати можливість підтримати
вас а також налаштувати на навчання у
цей складний для країни час
також незабаром будуть цікаві короткі
ролики з яких ви зможете дізнатись
мінімум три речі перше як опанувати себе
друге як налаштуватись на навчання і
третє як завжди мати гарний настрій До
речі Ці навички знадобляться вам не
тільки зараз а й впродовж всього життя
ми залучили найкращих українських
психологів а також тренерів з емоційного
інтелекту фахівців з міжнародних
організацій До речі емоційний інтелект
найважливіша навичка 21 століття і тепер
і ви зможете її опанувати я щиро бажаю
вам вдалого навчального року і говорю
разом з усіма повертайтесь до навчання
станіславе пасиві почули Дякую друзі ну
а зараз у мене до вас таке знаєте
запитання де можна Ну хоча б кілька
секунд але поміркувати Чи важко
опанувати хоча б одну іноземну мову
відповідь Це варто зусиль певних це
однозначно а декілька мов тим більше тим
паче що може бути красиво Тим більше що
ти коли розумієш що іноземна мова - це
відкрити вікно в твоєму житті до всього
світу так от А що для цього потрібно
наступний наш гість Він впевнений що
кожна людина здатна вивчити іноземну
мову і не одну головне правильно це
робити
а як саме ми дізнаємося просто зараз я
передаю слово в Італію зубкову відомому
психолінгвісту та Поліглот який навчає
людей п'яти іноземних мовам провів
наймасовіший урок з англійської мови
який потрапив до речі до Книги рекордів
Та є автором наймасовішого проекту з
вивчення англійської мови в Україні тож
пане Віталію прошу вам слово Доброго
ранку
Дякую
Вітаю всіх хто зараз нас дивиться
мені весь час задають одне й те саме
питання вітаю в тебе якась особлива
здібність до вивчення мов постійно так
чую таке чую я всім відповідаю ні
іноземну мову можу опанувати кожен
головне робити це правильно
кожна людина в світі здатна вивчити
будь-яку мову Не вірите от давайте з
вами зараз поекспериментуємо хто з вас
наприклад знає італійську мову
небагато людей правильно Давайте
перевіримо чи ви можете зрозуміти що я
зараз скажу цією мовою готові
біономе е Віталій
конюми Зубков Віталій Зубков номи
коньоми новини
в Італії про Інну України і його вадо
вадо іміталія Україна Італія вадо да
Україна Італія
іміталія Віко Віко Чао соно вітали
італіано нічого страну Сеньор
віталійноми Ну не коньоми зубкове гель
конеми
Скажіть будь ласка чи ви зрозуміли
загальну думку яку я зараз висловив Отже
для засвоєння будь-якої іноземної мови
головне створити правильні умови і тоді
все вийде Цей принцип я заклав в проект
lingva Skills і тепер усі учні можуть
безкоштовно вивчати англійську мову
знаходячись в будь-якому місці
повертайтесь до навчання та вчіть мови
правильно зі святом вас
[музика]
я багато слів вже зрозумів що ти смієшся
найголовніше що ми запам'ятали зараз зі
свіча пане Віталія але друзі насправді
якщо ви жартів дуже круто можна вивчати
різні іноземні мови Вже почала майже
вивчати данки і Шон біти що він дасть
фантастієш а good morning
про це пішов
Бачиш як надихнув на цей процес що
багатьох ти нас дивиться просто зараз
друзі дійсно вивчати мову - це потрібно
і свою удосконало знати іноземно також і
все це не випадково Ну чому Я ще почав
про німецьку говорити справді в тім що
до нас приєднуються заступниця директора
дёте інституту в Україні Катерина бук
Доброго дня вам пані Катерино Доброго
дня
Вітаю студія і щиро вітаю усіх дітей
молота батьків зі святом вас Дякую що ми
сьогодні змогли зібратися Сьогодні я
Хочу наголосити на трьох пропозиціях для
вас вивчення німецької мови
Перша наша пропозиція для вас хочу знати
як працює Привіт принтер чому в мушлі
шумить море
відповідь на ці запитання дізнайся у
нашому геміфікованому порталі Kinder Uni
вивчає німецьку мову безкоштовно в
цифровому Кіндер уні разом із професором
ейнштейном та чудовим роботом його тому
що з німецькою Ти знаєш більше До речі а
ти знаєш ти що європейські
суперкомп'ютер знаходиться в німецькому
в місті Юлій
це перший комп'ютер Європи який лише за
одну секунду може зробити більше
трильйона обчислювального операції
цікаво так а до нового навчального року
ми підготували 40 нових відеолекцій
Кіндер унії ти знаєш їх на наші
векторинці
друга наша пропозиція скоро восени усе
українській школі онлайн з'явиться новий
предмет
німецька мова ми готуємо чудовий
відеоуроки з німецької мови які
розміщуються на сайті всеукраїнської
школи онлайн
А ще недостатньо німецькою ні туди ось
наша третя пропозиція
запропонуй один із наших курсів
німецької мови для дітей та молоді
інформацію знайдеш на наші веб-сторінці
тут бажає Україні Перемоги тому що ми
Свобода та незалежність це основа того
що й наповнює життя сенсом у особисте
життя і життя демократичної громади
ваша школа готує вас до цього І ми на
вашому буці Отже Повертайтеся до
навчання
пані Катерина Дякуємо вам справді знаєш
зрозумілі абсолютно всім слова і
настанови Ну і ми від вивчення мов далі
переходимо вже до фізичного здоров'я
тому що звична для нас усіх фізрак яку
ми ще з дитинства пам'ятаємо що вона ми
обожнювали її біль ну реально обожнювали
але зараз цей предмет має набути нового
змісту А якого про це на власне розкаже
телевізійний ведучий громадський діяч та
керівник всеукраїнського проекту Juniors
Олександр Педан Вітаю Олександри
чого нам очікувати Ану давай
так друзі Привіт З 1 вересня з Днем
знань і Якщо говорити про фізкультуру то
насправді ми з нашою громадською
організацією Junior вже 5 років робимо
все для того щоб вона була більш цікавою
щоб вона вам подобалась ми вводимо нові
види спорту такі як черлідинг е-е
флорбол
фрізбіотімат петанк і так далі
небагайтеся не не лякайтеся цих слів
вони вам обов'язково сподобається в
цьому році До речі ми разом із дитячим
фондом ООН юнісеф Уявіть собі зробили
959 уроків онлайн які увійшли в
національний рекорд України і це було
дійсно веселі цікаві уроки і друзі
підручними матеріалами Я сам в них брав
участь які наші українські зірки
ми брали шкарпеточки підкидали їх ловили
вас вдома АА Мені дійсно хочеться щоб в
цьому році у нас була можливість
побачитися в офлайні щоб ми зустрілися
на спортивних майданчиках тому що
відкрию маленький секрет для чого
необхідна фізкультура по-перше для того
щоб ви тримали себе формі тонусі Бачите
я займаюсь трошки спортом мені 40 е
кажуть непогано виглядає а по-друге для
того щоби ви позбулися усіх стресів
знервованості тому що спорт і фізична
активність в цьому супер допомагає Ну і
по-третє найголовніше щоб ви знаходили
нових друзів тому що справжній друг
перевіряється на спортивному майданчику
скажу від себе в мене дійсно найкращі
друзі перевірені спортом тому я вам
бажаю класного навчального року
Щоб ви здобули нові знання Ну і
найголовніше знайшли нових друзів повер
повертатися до навчання
Спасибі тобі великий Дякуємо ставимо
лайк сердечко педано і Я впевнений друзі
що нашим учням Ну буде дуже цікаво
зайнятися особливо такою програмою яку
а-а про яку нам розказував тільки що
Саша я знову таки замислився і навіть
трошечки згадав а-а плате запитання А
для чого взагалі вчитись Ну мабуть кожна
дитина або вже на півдоросла людина
стала питання ну нащо нам ті навчання Ну
нащо ті знання і так далі Все це
потрібно взагалі виявляється і відповідь
доволі проста для того щоб підготуватись
до життя і визначитись з той самий
професією на майбутнє що це може бути у
Робітнича Професія - це може бути
будівельник науковець інженер блогер
лікар
програміст актор вчитель Головне щоб ця
професія була цікава вам і ви були до
неї готові у вас були до того здібності
А як же обрати тоді професію своєї мрії
запитаєте ви і будете на це це питання у
новому навчальному році також є
відповідь до нас долучається
координаторка українських освітніх хабіб
виконавчий директорка асоціації
інноваційної та цифрової освіти Марія
Богуслав Марія Доброго дня вітаємо
Вітаю
вам слово
Так дякую
Кожне з нас з дитинства мріє про якусь
професію чи сферу діяльності і зараз
саме коли ви вже навчаєтесь в класах
випускних або в останніх класах школи
саме час задуматися вже і визначитися
яку з професій вам треба опановувати щоб
ваше життя склалися успішно і не
довелося як кажуть кожного дня ходити на
роботу тому що ви будете займатися вашою
улюбленою справою для цього вам допоможе
наш надійний помічник штучний інтелект
саме Завдяки йому
вам буде зручно зрозуміти ваше сильні
сторони ваші типи особистості типи
інтелекту і цей штучний інтелект
допоможе вам підібрати ті професії в
яких ви будете максимально успішними і
корисними в суспільстві І власне
відчувати свою ефективність кожного дня
а також ви можете проконсультуватися з
кар'єрними консультантами це фахові
психологи які допоможуть вам роз'яснити
Деякі моменти допоможуть підібрати
правильно навчальний заклад або взагалі
Ви можете запитати в них
як яким чином будувати свою персональну
кар'єрну траєкторію все це Абсолютно
безкоштовно можна знайти на сайті
національного порталу з
профорієнтації та побудови кар'єри
оберіть професію своєї мрії і запрошую
вас на сайт вам Бажаю успіху в цьому
навчальному році і повертайтесь до школи
Дякуємо пані мрія оце вже дуже цікаво і
про штучний інтелект і про можливість да
пройти якесь якусь співбесіду або якісь
певні тести там з кадрових фахівцями з
тими хто займається саме профорієнтацією
щоб вже на цьому етапі випускних класах
для себе визначити взагалі а яка
професія мені ближче а якісь здібності
вони краще розвинені щоб я їх міг потім
примінити в реальному справжньому житті
тому що дійсно школа перш за все повинна
готувати до реального життя до того ким
кожна дитина бажає стати І власне для
цього має відповідні здібності а от чи
вдалося опанувати професію своєї мрії
нашому наступному гостю ми зараз
дізнаємося вже безпосередньо у нього
робота це наш співвітчизник який ми
пишаємося без вже більше є до нас
приєднується відомий співак соліст
популярної групи Антитіла зараз
доброволець сил територіальної оборони
збройних сил України Тарас Тополя Тарас
Тут друзі вітаємо Слава Україні
Героям слава навчання освіта виховання
неймовірно важливі саме завдяки цьому Ми
витягнемо нашу країну на вершину Я
впевнений ті хто зараз цей драматичний
час історії навчається
підвищують свої навички здобувають
освіту обов'язково
просунуть в Україну вперед у віртуальний
світ у космос у світі новацій це наш
ключик до майбутнього
і я хочу щоб ви це усвідомили почули
відчули що ваш труд терпіння
настирливість обов'язково дадуть
результати знаєте це і на опускаючи руку
насичуйте своє мізки знаннями А серце
цінностями Слава Україні
Серце наповнювати цінностями це та
саморушійна сила внутрішній такий поступ
який допомагати допомагає йти вперед
також знаєш прикладом власне оцих
цінностей то наскільки людина може бути
і талановитою наскільки можна любити
свою країну ти захищати її це справді
приклад для багатьох українців Друзі Ну
і один знань попри те що ми всі
об'єднані спільною трагедією війною
завжди було святом а в будь-яке свято
треба внести щось таке легке насичене
таке щось повітряне яскраве ну
яке воно ростечко ти хотіла сказати так
родзиночка має бути в фіналі свята
знаєте зараз на прямому зв'язку з нами
друзі з вами
Тіна Кароль українська співачка яка і
вміє співати кажуть і ще є голосами
дельфінів привіт
від студія Привіт усім надзвичайна рада
вас бачити а особливо наших учнів Вітаю
вас з початком навчального року
І хочу сказати усім хлопчикам та
дівчаткам що навчатися це дуже важливо
адже саме Від вас залежить якою буде
Україна
Повертайтеся до навчання або
окрім на це
[музика]
Моє ім'я Батьківщина
лелеки легке крило
Моє ім'я Україна
І сонечка тепло
Моє ім'я Вишиванка я хрестик на постний
Моє ім'я синє небо я сонях малий півник
[музика]
слух Україна - це я
мамині пісні
Україна
[музика]
моя рідна Степ широкий
Моє ім'я хліба спарк останній шкільний
дзвіночок на себем вітром туман
[музика]
Надія Моє ім'я то любов
Моє ім'я чиста Мрія і віра що з нами
[музика]
Бог дату і слова
мами
[музика]
ні
[оплески]
[музика]
Обі
дилась
моєї твої поля
переможець голову Воля може Моє ім'я то
Рубина
родина твоя батьків моє ім'я добре слово
що збереже цей світ
так тобі
[музика]
Сла
ва
Господи
[музика]
Україна
це ти
Ну що друзі перший урок нового
навчального року відходить до завершення
і Ми дякуємо всім вам а від вашого імені
Ми хочемо подякувати всім гостям які
сьогодні взяли участь у цьому уроці і ще
раз нагадати що цей урок для вас
організували Міністерство освіти і науки
України інститут модернізації змісту
освіти і асоціація інноваційної та
цифрової освіти всім Дякуємо за
підтримку Ґете інституту Федеративної
Республіки Німеччини ну і Ми впевнені що
ви дійсно надихнулись бажанням вчитись
незважаючи на те в якому форматі вам це
буде зручніше зробити в очному
дистанційному форматі в будь-якому разі
друзі ми вважаємо вам успіхів і
пам'ятайте про те що знання - Це ваша і
наша зброя це сила це ота маленька
цеглиночка в масштабах всієї країни де
ми можемо будувати наше майбутнє а він
далі на якому все буду а відтак і те що
Україна буде то залежить від нас і від
вас бо знання
сила давай три чотири повер
тайтеся
[музика]